as the Canadians control the face off played
back of the goal by Kaden ghouly number 21
and that comes to Center grabbed by cofi he
darts in shoots it right on goal and a save
by Hofer in Edmonton in the western leag Nick
ly trying to get away from Coffield and then
Capp in for Paro up the ice with s to S he
comes in back to p and a save by Mono from
Monahan who gets knocked down and now the
blue is a pass ahead and a break for Shan
he's in the clear and he shoots it high on a
personal break now pass in front CYO he scores
[Music] Kyu Braden Shand here had the initial
opportunity rips it just a little high but stays
with it and then Jordan kyou makes a beine right
for the back door here strong lower hand boom back
of the net good clears denying entries things
like that go a long way well and they continue
to stand up at the blue line here Oscar sunquist
doing a great job as well now a drop pass for new
hook he comes in pass in front slowski shoots
and he scores what a play by the 19-year-old
uray slowski and it's [Applause] 1-1 well that's
an unfortunate goal right there throughout their
power play see here comes down low just a little
shot it goes right between the arm and the pad of
Joel Hofer we'll get a better look at it here
as the Canadians forward comes in yeah kind of
an awkward shot looked like he was trying to go
even higher with it kind of handcuffed himself
a little bit on this cuz the puck was on edge
and then it squeaks that time there just gets
the puck in for a line change Here Comes cof
and he darts in former Hobie Baker winner out
of Wisconsin at the line now Jacka pass and
a shot from the point right on Save By Hofer
rebound loose there and C gets it ahead that
it wasn't Tucker's fault it Monahan who flied
the stick up there either way doesn't matter you
got to kill this off yeah mono one for one in the
power play hope for big pad save on monan in
a loone there yeah he's been real aggressive
on the penalty kill now on a hand broken up by
Faulk good re there and now Justin Faulk back
one-on-one shoots it up high and a save there by
Mono shoots it and a save rebound hit the side
of the goal that was Pearson with the second
opportunity and the blues have killed it off
Gallagher shoots it right on goal and it's saved
by Hur and no rebound and Arbor Jacky again now
new hook a pass on the tap of Anderson coming
in and shoots it right on goal and a save by
Hofer they've already lost Kirby doc Young Center
icean for the year with an ACL here's Kyu coming
in shooting one on goal and it's saved by Mono
just love the Saturday night game here in St
Louis people are into it music's going John they
got the Heritage jerseys on Play here's a great
move by Thomas he comes in shoots he scores
what a shot by Robert the Thomas and it's
2-1 and that's how you get them
on their feet right there John
Robert Thomas the flick of the wrist the
blues have been pushing up the ice doing
a great job in transition got to like
Pavo bich going to the net here little
bit of a distraction for the Montreal
Canadians golender but Robert Thomas no
hesitation play is back out as the blues
have killed it off one shot for Montreal
here's a drive at the line a shot tip there
and let it go and that's a good save by hoper
that was tipped it's exactly what the goenda to
become boy that's a tough save to make too like
three or four different screens on this one
Joel H for getting big above the body there
gallager in front of the net reading the tip
and then just closing everything up one low for
Gallagher kept in by Harris comes in front look
out hulur came over made the save on Coffield and
Montreal to center now dorak that's blocked
by the youngster Tucker and played out Shan
ahead another odd man break for the blue Kyu
in front wide open they score sod Sensational
goal 3-1 blows take Le BL do here Tucker with
a great Play Moves it up the wall Braden Shen
seals Off the Wall pokes it up to Jordan kyou who
who's patient with the puck he comes in he waits
sod opens up in that one-timer position doesn't
end up one-timing it he wants to make to take a
two goal lead neighbors trips up here's Gallagher
he'll pound it back in and now Breo for Ley check
back of the goal Center Gallagher wide open and
he scores and Gallagher gets Montreal back within
one we get a good look at it Paro
bumping the puck back back yeah
that's a tough one I don't think the
blues are going to call any kind of
goalie interference on this mon Canadians
players outside of the paint yeah that was
contact I I don't think he get the
call if you make that yeah in the
corner for f and up the middle
but kept in Baron knock down and
a break for tarup Cho he's in the CLA
shorthanded he's got Stars short-handed
goal well that's certainly one way to change the
atmosphere Joel hord does a good job of moving the
puck but then Pavo bich here like a dog on the
bone gets a piece of that Puck and then tchenko
he's Off to the Races shows forehand back in looks
like he's going to dig NOP goes back and fires it
over the pad and the blues bench goes wild they
love it at the same time he had 10 goals last
year in 69 games now Kyro great move great pass
they score Shen his first of the Season what a
play that line has been electric tonight
here at the Enterprise Center but again it
start with nice faceof win Middle Lane Drive
kyou pulls it to the middle and hits Braden
Shen back door but this doesn't happen if
bra Brandon sad doesn't drive through the
middle of the ice creates that opening
needs it back for Paro and that shot a
wobbly bobbly shot wide of the goal now
Center L Davis wide open back door BL is
wide open and he can't get it over mono
what a pass by B navage and now for C
davage almost got it in behind the defense and
now it's C again empty net here from mreal by
the way Blue's coming in and they score empty net
goal for the [Music] blues now Casper C gets on
the score [Applause] sheet there was going to
be a penalty on on the Montreal Canadians for
that holding and then fosi coming in pass
on the wing C field through his legs what
a play and it's shot just wide I think by
Suzuki what a play by cofi and then a shot
High by sovi and kept in oh Sun just buries MAF
and a shot for the line they score might have
been tipped and it's 63 with the shot on that
sun with a great hit then Coffield bringing it
up high here then Suzuki in front unattended
to gets his stick on the puck I believe we'll
get a good look at it right here yeah right
there off the stick nothing Joel hord kich
back for the Canadians on for Evans cazetta
shot handled by huler in front Hofer a save
at the buzzer on kovich and that'll do it as
the Blues win 6-3 and sweep the weekend series